feasible is something I've always wanted
to do because I I think just in general
uh American snacks are just full of so
much
horrible ingredients to be honest and
they're not I don't know I feel like
there also just hasn't been any
innovation in American snacks in quite a
while
um and so that's just something I've
always been pretty passionate about the
thing we built that from scratch so we
hired the CEO and built a team around
them and we we spent probably over two
and a half years before we even launched
just like building the right team
figuring things out and making sure it
was actually ran the way I wanted
um which festivals has just been
crushing it's
it's very interesting uh this is
something I've never talked about
publicly but having products in retail
it's like before feastables everything I
had done was online so if you wanted to
you know anything from the cocoa peace
brand you'd have to buy it online and
ship it to you but feastfuls now that
you know because our first product
chocolate bars we started putting that
in retail locations so like for example
Walmart it's it's crazy like it's just
it doesn't make sense how if you're
which I guess it does for because we get
100 million views of videos so a lot of
people know us if I go stand in Walmart
those people recognize me and ask for
photos like if I still don't enough I
could take 150 photos today in Walmart
200 whatever it is so obviously it makes
sense those people go fight feastfuls
but then you just multiply that by every
Walmart in America and it just gets so
crazy and I didn't think we'd be doing
the kind of Revenue we are and we're
about to launch in some other I don't
know if I'm allowed to say so whatever
but other big retail you know locations
and convenience stores and like by the
end of next year we could be in like 40
fifty thousand locations and the numbers
just don't make sense you know what are
some interesting challenges about
scaling there that surprised you the
biggest problem which I didn't think
would be was just keeping the shelves in
Walmart stock to be honest like it would
have to supply it was supply chain it
was brutal well even then sometimes like
you know you get them the stuff and
they're like it takes them like a day or
two to put it out in that specific
location and I I had to stop promoting
it because every time I'd mention it
like 40 of people would just be like
it's not there it's not in Walmart or I
can't buy it and so there's like a
three ish month period where I just
didn't promote festivals because I was
scared that someone would go by and it's
just not there and so like it took us a
very long time to catch up to the demand
and also it's not like we have unlimited
money so but now we're relatively caught
up in
um keeping up but it's gonna be
interesting because now this year in
2023 we're gonna basically you know
10x the amount of locations they're in
so or and we're gonna try to launch new
products so we're in for an interesting
ride but yeah I just hate I hate when I
tell people you know like hey go try
this product and then they go in their
local Walmart and eventually other
places and it's not there it's just so
brutal you know they made that whole
journey out there and they can get it
and so that was really it
um
besides that no it's it's been doing way
better than I ever thought